we're holding hands staring at the door
my siblings and I were waiting for my
mother to come back from the hospital
she was there because my grandmother had
cancer surgery that day finally the
doors opened and she said she's gone
she's gone she started sobbing and
immediately said we must make
arrangements
your grandmother's dying wish was to be
buried back home in Korea I was barely
12 years old and when the shock wore off
my mother's words were ringing in my
ears my grandmother wanted to be buried
back home we had moved from Korea to
Argentina six years prior without
knowing any Spanish or how we're going
to make a living and upon arrival
we're immigrants who had lost everything
so we had to work really hard to rebuild
their lives so he hadn't occurred to me
that after all these years back home
still in Korea it made me ponder where I
would want to be buried someday where
home was for me and the answer was not
obvious and this really bothered me so
this episode launched a lifelong quest
for my identity I was born in Korea the
land of kimchi raised in Argentina where
ate so much steak that I'm probably 80%
cow by now and I was educated in the US
where I became addicted to peanut butter
during my childhood I felt very much
Argentinean but my looks betrayed me at
times I remember on the first day of
middle school my Spanish literature
teacher came into the room she scanned
all my classmates and she said you you
have to get a tutor otherwise you won't
has this class but by then I was fluent
in Spanish already so he sat as though I
could be either a Korean or Argentinean
but not both it felt like a zero-sum
game where I had to give up my old
identity to be able to gain or earn a
new one so when I was 18 I decided to go
to Korea hoping that finally I could
find a place to call home but there
people ask me why do you speak Korean
with a Spanish accent and you must be
Japanese because of your big eyes and
your foreign body language and so it
turns out that I was too Korean to be
Argentinian but to Argentinian to be
Korean and this was a pivotal
realization to me I had failed to find
that place in the world to call home but
how many Japanese looking Koreans who
speak with a Spanish accent or even more
specific Argentinian accent do you think
are out there perhaps this could be an
advantage it was easy for me to stand
out which couldn't hurt in a world that
was rapidly changing where skills could
become obsolete overnight so I stopped
looking for that 100% commonality with
the people that I met instead I realized
that oftentimes I was the only overlap
between groups of people that were
usually in conflict with each other
so with this realization in mind I
decided to embrace all of the different
versions of myself even allow myself to
reinvent myself at times so for example
in high school I have to confess I was
mega nerd I had no sense of fashion the
glasses ankle hairstyle you can get the
idea I think actually I only had friends
because I shared my homework that's true
but once at university I was able to
find a new identity for myself and the
nerd became a popular girl but it was in
my tea so I don't know if I can take too
much credit or not as they say over
there the odds are good but the goods
are odd
I switched major so many times that my
advisors joked that I should get a
degree in random studies I tell this to
my kids and then over the years I have
gained a lot of different identities I
started as an inventor entrepreneur
social innovator then I became an
investor a woman in tag a teacher and
most recently I became a mom or as my
toddler says repeatedly Wow
day and night even my accent was so
confused dad it origin was so obscure
that my friends called it Rebecca needs
but reinventing yourself can be very
hard
you can face a lot of resistance at
times when I was nearly done with my PhD
I got beaten by that entrepreneurial
Abad I was in Silicon Valley and so
writing a thesis in the basement didn't
seem as interesting as starting my own
company so I went to my very traditional
Korean parents were here today with the
task of letting them know that I was
going to drop out from my ph.d program
you see my students and I are the first
generation to go to university so for
your final of immigrants this was kind
of a big deal you can imagine how this
conversation was going to go but
fortunately I had a secret weapon with
me which was a chart that had the
average income of all of the graduates
from Stanford PhD programs and then the
average income of all of the dropouts
from Stanford graduate program
I must tell you you know this chart was
definitely skewed by the founders of
Google but my mom looked at a chart and
she said Oh failure follow your passion
hi mom now today my identity quest is no
longer to find my tribe it's more about
allowing myself to embrace all of the
possible permutations of myself and
cultivating diversity within me and not
just around me my voice now are three
years and five months old today and they
were already born with three
nationalities and four languages
I should mention now that my husband is
doctor from Denmark just in case I don't
have enough culture shots in my life I
decided to marry a Danish guy in fact I
think my kids will be the first Vikings
will have a hard time growing a beard
when they become older yeah we'll have
to work on that but I really hope that
they will find that their multiplicity
it's going to open and create a lot of
doors for them in their lives and that
they can use this is a way to find
commonality in a way in the world that's
increasingly global today I hope that
instead of feeling anxious and worried
that they don't fit in that one box or
that their identity will become
irrelevant someday that they can feel
free to experiment and to take control
of their personal narrative and identity
I also hope that they would use their
unique combination of values and
languages and cultures and skills to
help create a world where identities are
no longer used to alienate what looks
different but rather to bring together
people and most importantly I really
hope that they find tremendous joy in
going through this uncharted territory
because I know I have now as for my
grandmother her last wish was also her
last lesson to me it turns out that it
was never about going back to Korea and
being buried there it was about resting
next to her son who had died long before
she moved to Argentina what mattered to
her was not the ocean that divided her
past a new world it was about finding
common ground thank you
[Applause]